großeinsatz im rockermilieu eine
bundesweite razzia gegen die rockerbande
united tribuns hunderte polizisten sind
im einsatz und da sind die bilder vom
frühen morgen vom einsatz am clubhaus
dieser rocker in remscheid um punkt
sechs uhr war dort zugriff und
zeitgleich auch an zig anderen orten und
objekten dieser gang der united tribuns
ja was ist das für eine truppe eine
gruppe die sich vor fast 20 jahren
gegründet hat in baden württemberg sich
dann ausgebreitet hat vor allen dingen
auch in nordrhein westfalen
das sind rocker vor allem vom balkan
hier sehen sie den mittlerweile im
ausland lebenden boss dieser bande die
sich zuletzt brutale kämpfe geliefert
hat auf der straße auch mit den hells
angels hier sehen sie bilder aus leipzig
damals von der wilden schießerei im juni
war das damals gab es einen toten auch
in den straßen und auch aufgrund dessen
ist diese rockerbande mittlerweile seit
einigen tagen verboten deshalb jetzt
also diese großrazzia mit
spezialeinheiten der polizei
sechs uhr morgens wie hier in remscheid
stürmen zeitgleich bundesweit hunderte
polizisten darunter auch schwer
bewaffnete beamte der spezialeinheiten
über 50 gebäude in ganz deutschland
razzia gegen die rocker der united
tribuns
die gruppierung die hauptsächlich aus
kampfsportlern und türstehern besteht
ist heute durch bundesinnenministerium
nancy faeser verboten worden hintergrund
sind immer wieder schwere gewalttaten
der rocker mit mehreren toten sowie ihre
verbindungen zur organisierten
kriminalität
[Musik]
schwerpunkt der aktion sind nordrhein
westfalen und baden württemberg in köln
sprengte das sek in einem
mehrfamilienhaus mit einem lauten knall
die wohnungstür eines mutmaßlichen
anführers der united tribuns auch
ermittler des bundeskriminalamtes sind
an der wohnung in remscheid wurde ein
clubheim durchsucht polizisten boten
dafür die eingangstür auf
alle symbole der rocker sind ab sofort
verboten zudem wird das vereinsvermögen
beschlagnahmt
durchsuchungen soll es aktuell auch noch
in bayern und schleswig holstein geben
und wir sprechen mit unseren reportern
vor ort sebastian bringe in remscheid
und chefreporter frank schneider ist
dort in köln frank was hat sich da heute
in den frühen morgenstunden alles
abgespielt
der zugriff erfolgte bundesweit
zeitgleich um 6 uhr das macht die
polizei mal ganz bewusst so damit sich
die täter untereinander nicht warmen
können wir können das einmal hier ganz
kurz zeigen wir stehen hier an dem
mehrfamilienhaus und hier vorne auf dem
gehweg sind die police des sek angerollt
und dann sind die beamten hier ganz
leise an diesem lokal vorbeigeschlichen
hinten zu der eingangstür und haben sich
dann dort aufgestellt sind leise ins
gebäude und kurz nachdem sie im gebäude
war hörte man dann auf einmal einen
ohrenbetäubenden knall sie haben damit
einen sogenannten spreng schlauch die
eingangstür gesprengt und sind dann in
diese wohnung wenn man befürchtete dass
der mann der dort wohnt und zur an
führerschaft gehören soll auch bewaffnet
sein könnte es hat sich wohl nicht
bestätigt aber die polizei wollte auf
nummer sicher gehen in dieser gruppe ist
einfach gefährlich das haben in den
letzten jahren gesehen ist wurde brutal
gewalt angewandt es wurden waffen
eingesetzt und die bundesinnenminister
hat ja heute auch gesagt diese hohe
gewaltbereitschaft und gefährlichkeit
war auch wirklich eine gefahr für die
allgemeinheit in deutschland und wir
haben ja kürzlich auch bei den rocker
auseinandersetzungen gesehen in duisburg
david mitten am hellichten tag herum
geschossen wir haben es in leipzig auch
gesehen die harte tour wir uns gegen die
hells angels und man wollte einfach
nicht weitere gefahren in kauf nehmen
und hat gesagt die werden jetzt verboten
und vielleicht noch eine erklärung auch
dazu die menschen gibt es natürlich
weiterhin heute ist auch kein haft
gegangen man nimmt ihnen dieses
martialische auftreten dann nimmt in
dieser gemeinschaft man nimmt ihnen
diese symbole und das hat beim kunden
verbot bei den hells angels und bandidos
auch schon sehr geholfen die man die das
sind mittlerweile auch verboten jetzt
die united tribuns und in meinen augen
ist es vielleicht nur eine frage der
zeit ist auch die hells angels verboten
werden danke frank du hast gerade schon
gesagt die bundesinnenministerium hat
sich dazu heute früh schon geäußert zu
dieser bundesweiten razzia also das
verbot vor einigen tagen jetzt in kraft
getreten und dann direkt an diesem tag
an dem das verbot in kraft wird eben
diese bundesweite aktion vor allen
dingen eben bei euch in nordrhein
westfalen noch mal die pressemitteilung
heute früh gleich raus gegangen ist vom
bundesinnenministerium wo eben nancy
faeser die innenministerin nochmal eine
einschätzung gibt ihre einschätzung über
diese united tribuns weiter nach
remscheid so bast sebastian prengel dort
vor dem clubhaus dieser united tribuns
und man muss sagen vor dem ex klub aus
dem alle zeichen dort vernichtet heute
früh
genauso sax ist das clubhaus der united
tribuns gewesen die polizei ist hier
heute morgen um 6 uhr angerückt man hat
das haus umstellt die zufahrtsstraßen
wurden gesperrt und dann hat es hier
umfangreiche durchsuchungsmaßnahmen
gegeben hat hier natürlich alles
mitgenommen was hinweise auf diesen klub
gibt es geht dabei natürlich auch um
vermögenswerte aber auch um schilder und
plakate einfach um alles
was halt hinweise gibt man darf ja die
farben dieses klubs und die abzeichen
nicht mehr tragen da ist ein lkw
angefordert worden und mit dem hat die
polizei alles abtransportiert
also alles ist weg aber wie groß ist
deine befürchtung dass man sich dann
eben nicht offiziell organisiert dass
man doch irgendwie zusammen bleibt als
gruppe
ja das muss man natürlich abwarten also
die befürchtung ist ja gewesen hat die
gewalt weiter eskaliert wir haben es
gerade schon gehört das hat immer wieder
schießereien gegeben mit toten und frank
schneider hat es gerade gesagt der club
ist weg aber die menschen sind noch da
deshalb muss man abwarten was jetzt hier
in zukunft passiert dann kann sebastian
prengel und frank schneider unsere
reporter dort im einsatz seit den ganz
frühen morgenstunden heute bei dieser
bundesweiten großrazzia gegen die united
tribuns diese ex-broker bande danke euch
bei diese rockergruppe vor allem hatte
kampfsportler und türsteher die stehen
immer wieder eingeweiht hat morden in
verbindung
[Musik]
für uns ist nur der realität respekt ist
ein punkte sind sehr wichtig die sind
gesellschaft verloren gegangen und das
ist das problem einfach und jetzt hätten
die brüder in der masse wie das er jetzt
[Musik]
sechs monate lang war so im falle der
fälle habe es noch ein bisschen ein jahr
bis man von apple sein ist alles ist
jetzt zwischen der schnellste weg ist
um des kanals
[Musik]
wir sehen keine spät denn wir sehen wir
sehen das soll jetzt schon mal geschafft
hatten sich vor und schaut und der trend
geht eigentlich auch in die mutter
zeitung
grundwerte sein weil wir genügend gründe
haben etwas
geräten aus genutzt ein großer teil
davon oder bei und auch im elsass
entschlossen seien langfristig mozart
und es das ist schon da
[Musik]
wenn ihr mann nicht
bei uns ein einmaliges stattgefunden hat
war für mich dass ich keine ahnung ob
wir dazu erzählt und so konnte das
unternehmen
reagiert sonst das ist eine entscheidung
haben es wird niemand gezwungen bewusst
zu sein und da gibt es kein krieg und er
wechselt und wechsel
[Musik]
der letzte weg und deshalb
sorgen der letzte weg immer die gewalt
sein wenn es darum geht aber wir werden
die ersten steine schmeißt der bekannte
den nächsten morgen
[Musik]
ich werde das alles zu geben es ist das
will ich musste alles zu gewinnen was
kommt jetzt ich sage es zugeben dass im
ersten test gemacht habe dass ich werde
erst in nächster zeit geben also ist ja
ich habe jetzt einen anlauf 14 antworten
vorbereitungen so zu machen dass um die
nächste runde gehen also ist manchmal
sag mal so gewollt
das schlimmste ist ein jahr aber hier
schon meine kinder sie dürfen also
[Musik]
das also sind sie diese balkan rocker
von den united tribuns gegen die heute
eine großrazzia in ganz deutschland lief
vor jahren 219 haben unsere
bild-reporter diese aufnahmen mit ihnen
gemacht
[Musik]